peuple
à
alors vous êtes alice bon pion et vous
jeudi l'ambiance et vous êtes de vrais
humaine vous êtes né en 1889
c'est une grande détresse pire cela des
inaugurations bateau en amérique nous
car il est partout et deux jours après
nous les laissions en effet mais est-ce
que vous êtes vraiment pareil parce que
vous avez les mêmes goûts exactement les
mêmes pensées et exactement monsieur
nous sommes passés en justice pour un
divorce qu'on ne savait pas de coin est
alors le juge dit vous ma pile et
l'appelle mademoiselle à lisbourg billon
je ne présente le président me dit et
m'interrogent suis fait ma déposition
évidemment et puis je dors ensuite on
appelle juillet alors aidé au gardien
lui des mais vous êtes à tous
l'arrivée l'amérique vous m'appelez la
même ils vont me faire venir la mer et
des parts dans lequel président je vous
appelle au alors je me suis reparti on
était stupéfaits 0,7 l hilarité par tout
en mesure et que ses avocats aux gros
coups on voudrait de la bande annonce il
nous avons dû beaucoup de temps a encore
à huy des dentistes à paris mais même
avec arrive oui les bleus
pourquoi parce que nous ne prenons pas
de détails
nous ne voulions pas le terrain nous
avons trouvé même un big n oui monsieur
tête tranchée il est peut-être taille
était en diamants vous savez nous avons
bien ri fait bâtir et il paraît que vous
allez à l'elysée
mais oui je tue des cases de juin quelle
joie de revenir oui nous avions la place
d'honneur moi je t'ai à côté à la bouche
du président d'albi à table et moi
la présidente de la république est
fautive elle à la droite
de quoi avez vous parlé ensemble eh bien
il m'a interviewé oui alors je lui dis
que j'étais le tordant évidemment et que
j'étais jumez médias en effet il est
votre soeur jumelle et auprès de madame
la présidente odile à moi je l'appelais
planti très heureux merci au président
wade
après nos souvenirs pour voir le jour
aujourd'hui mon président à l'autre
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup de mon fils
qui lui demandait des bouteilles à noël
après quand il était arrêté
j'aidais mon président vous faites de
joli voyage
vous êtes allée en egypte oui alors il
dit je suis dit est ce que madame la
présidente a pu supporter le climat
elle m'a dit oui oui oui alors est-ce
que vous avez vous été bien accueillie
très bien accueillie avec enthousiasme
et il y en a bien dégoûté
et demoiselles cetc l'église où vous
avez été baptisé certifi cat isis est la
première commune unique
oui nous emmener le 12 mai et nous avons
été baptisés le 14 e mail des jours
après ma naissance
[Musique]
ans
et alors vous idée de la musique à une
union de kalou avait avoué à quatre
mains à quatre mains toujours à 84 jours
de mer damant délit il m'a fallu avis
bons joueurs aux bons moments dans le
cadre du métier tu étais on nous a vendu
beaucoup de regrets quant au revenu de
la guerre de 18 des xi a fallu de
l'argent
nous n'avions pas d'argent il appartient
nous avons pleuré c'était notre patiente
et aide à midi au le piano et la danse
et la danse il attend d'abondantes et
est ce que les amants potentiels
mais qu'est-ce qui en double ici à
l'oriental et les deux fauteuils pareil
vous avez de vie pareille de chansons
d'only toujours minutes invité ben la
nuit vous ne pourriez pas vous vous
séparez et pourtant douter vous dit des
lits individuels ne sont jamais quittés
nous quitterons la séparation
si la mort qui ne s'est pas fait nous
demandons qu'une chose monsieur c'est de
mourir un temps voyez vous que tu as
fait pas beau enfin c'est bien le même
jour il mourir le même site a fait
disparaître même jour tout est parfait
un maître dans la main henry
celle qui restreignent le cul serait
malheureux laisse mourir d'ennui
[Musique]